with season five b of lucifer here it's
time to hunt through all the new
episodes for those delicious easter eggs
and hilarious details the crew snuck in
for all us lucy fans
so many easter eggs from our previous
adventures did you spot them all
yipikaya movie lovers i'm jan and in
this video i'm revealing over 50
heavenly details you missed in part two
of lucifer season five
spoilers ahead of course so take care
lucifer proves he's the devil of his
word at the start of episode nine
see this guy dancing at lurks as lucy
plays footloose on the piano
well he's the security guard that
lucifer made a devilish deal with in the
mid-season finale
i want to be a dancer well you're in
luck barishnikov
i'll hire you make your footloose dreams
come true what do you say given dan's
previous relationship with the goddess
meeting her husband was always going to
be super
awkward so i bet he was glad to see
lucifer distract god with some snacks
dad why don't i show you the vending
machines have you tried cool ranch puffs
and as we know from season one those
particular snacks are lucy's favorites
cool ranch puff it's funny isn't it you
think the king of hellfire be more of a
flaming hot guy
i love the symmetry of these shots of
lucifer and god when they end up in a
therapy session at dr linders as it
shows that father and son have more in
common than they might think
pointing to how lucifer will become god
in the season finale
and if you look carefully you can see a
parenting book called how to raise
successful people on linda's desk which
is doubtless reading for his son charlie
but it also feels fitting for the
high-powered people currently occupying
her couch
the musical episode is an absolute blast
with lively performances busby berkeley
style choreography
a cameo from singer songwriter debbie
gibson and yes even god starts bopping
along
on top of that we also get plenty of
signs of what's to come by the end of
the season
dan's concerns over having slept with
god's wife which means i'm definitely
going to hell
and the song he sings foreshadow amena
deals discovery that his friend isn't in
heaven
lucifer shutting down a flame with his
hand and his clothes burning up while he
remains unscathed
you're okay yes of course i am
foreshadow his flaming fate in heaven
and signal that ultimately he'll emerge
unharmed
and then there are the literal signs we
see chloe and lucifer standing by at the
school as she tells him she has faith in
him and that she's sure he'll work
things out with his dad
flying to the top in just one day and
another victory on its way say the signs
pointing to chloe and lucy's heavenly
ascent in the finale
and team lucifer's triumph over his
villainous twin
at the gym of self-styled fitness guru
to the stars kristoff is a bunch of
posters of well-known clients he's
worked with
all of whom have been part of chloe and
lucy's cases at some point there's the
cast of lieutenant diablo the network tv
show that's a hilariously ott version of
lucifer
anders holobay a murdered dj whose body
was taken over by a demon in the season
4 finale
then there's a blazing banshees a roller
derby team involved in a murder kidnap
case and their rivals the derby divas
the bobby lowe show features a comedian
who stole jokes from another comic that
ended up being murdered before he could
reveal the truth
azara is a pop sensation whose life was
threatened in the episode let pinhead
sing
as for top meet that's an exclusive
celebrity dating app whose designer was
murdered
and apparently kristoff is featured on
the cabin a hit reality tv
program ella loves where a contestant
was killed in season 4.
given so many of the clients in the
posters are now dead it certainly brings
new meaning to the sign
bodies by kristoff when lucifer and
chloe go to interview a murder suspect
who owns an adventure park he gets the
wrong end of the stick and tries to flee
the scene in one of his go-karts
i thought you were arresting me for the
zx3 it's an illegal chemical used in
street racing
surprisingly useful in other ways we're
familiar this is a throwback to season
two
where lucy went to hell and back to get
the formula for the antidote to save
chloe after she was poisoned
and zx3 was the final ingredient needed
to create that antidote a chemical
called zx3 super rare super illegal in a
somewhat ironic twist
the same chemical that was used to save
her life back then winds up ending one
this season
yeah we found traces of zx3 and the fuel
that burned down the kingdom
most crucially though the fact this
super rare chemical crops up again at
the start of season 5b foreshadows how
chloe will need saving from death once
more in the season finale
in an effort to work on his relationship
with his father lucifer takes him to the
precinct but god's reaction when he
discovers lucy doesn't have a throne
office or even a desk is priceless and
dennis haysbert delivers the line
perfectly
he has a desk maybe if you work hard
enough you might one day
rise to this man's level this comment
must really sting as
lucifer is not only being compared
unfavorably to detective douche but
it'll probably also remind him of how
chloe turned him down in season two when
he asked for a desk next to hers
i should get my own desk not happening
right next yours would probably be best
definitely not happening of course their
relationship was at a very different
stage to that by season 5a and lucifer
was happy to see chloe make herself at
home at his desk in lux
this desk has never looked so good when
team lucifer tries stalling their face
off with michael to give maze time to
arrive
they break into song to pretend that
god's back but this isn't the first time
the embassy hammers you can't touch this
has cropped up on the show
in season 4 during their investigation
into the death of a realtor ella also
broke out the 90s track
stop camera time
in the midst of his insane adventures in
episode 12
dan tells ella he needs some advice to
get inside the criminal mind
i actually do know how to fake the
perfect murder because
i've been working on it for my novel
it's about a forensic scientist
who talks to ghosts ella first mentioned
that book in season three
i'm actually writing my own book about a
forensic scientist who talks to ghost
and it's based on her own friendship
since she was a child with a ghost named
ray ray
continuing the ghostly theme in another
episode ella wears a t-shirt with the
pun holy sheet on it that features a
ghost wearing a halo which is perfect
because that ghost that ella believes
she met as a child is actually a holy
being
lucifer's sister asriel in episode 11 as
a doctor gets ready to perform her
latest surgery she says
it's a beautiful day to operate which is
a play on the line it's a beautiful day
to save lives from the long-running
medical drama grey's anatomy
when lucifer arrives at an aquarium
where a body's been dumped in the shark
tank the first thing he says is
sharks one of earth's most misunderstood
creatures
definitely correcting that when i'm god
which is a throwback to season three
where he decided there were better ways
to spend his time
than trying to kill pierce aka kane
there are far better ways to spend my
time oh
take a nude painting class by that pet
shark i've always wanted
the number on the ticket lucy gets when
he leaves his car with a valet is 666.
the number of the beast in the book of
revelation and widely associated with
the antichrist or
devil this isn't the first time that
number's appeared for example it was
also tattooed on lucifer's torso
and when lucy appeared during an
arrowverse crossover event we learnt
that he lives on earth 666.
when god pops up at a crime scene and
tells chloe he's made himself human
lucifer makes a joke of it oh he does
inexplicable things from time to time
massive feels pomegranates the
gallbladder as throw away as that gag is
the mention of pomegranates caught my
attention as they've appeared on the
show before
with several paintings of them in the
lore office of charlotte the goddess
which is fitting as some scholars
believe that pomegranates not apples
were the fruit that tempted adam and eve
in the garden of eden
when chloe asks a medium where she was
during a murder she replies
giving a reading to uh programming exec
at fox oh good luck with that lucifer's
comment is a hilarious burn on the
show's previous home fox which canceled
the series after its third season
following which an online campaign by
lucy fans saw it picked up by netflix
as a menadil excitedly reveals he wants
to join the police and would love to
work with dan one day his friend's
response isn't anywhere near as
supportive as he'd hoped
yeah an angel and a detective solving
crimes makes total sense
of course we love meta moments like this
one in the series which basically sums
up the premise of the show
and is a spin on lucy's song crime
solving devil
it makes sense don't overthink it
during lucifer's mission to find out
which of his siblings will help him
rather than michael become god he says
to his brother jophiel
i'm assuming you're team lucifer which
is a call back to the season one episode
hashtag team lucifer where corrupt cop
malcolm told a mena deal he wasn't going
to help him kill lucy anymore
unless you got a better offer hashtag
team lucifer
the day season 5a dropped on netflix tom
ellis was straight on social media
tweeting hashtag michael as a dick
and a shout out to that trending topic
made it into season 5b
when jophiel and lucifer discuss
michael's nefarious ways
whispering in dad's ear making him think
he was losing his powers in the first
place
all so he could take over now yeah
michael's kind of
he's a massive at the start of the
season finale michael plays an off-key
version of the popular jazz song
heart and soul which is often performed
as a piano duet as it was by chloe and
lucifer in season one
michael's out of tune performance and
the fact he plays by himself
fits perfectly with his whole character
and emphasizes how totally at odds he is
in everything with his musical and
sociable twin brother
also intriguingly two of the times this
particular song was popped up in the
series it happened
shortly before a reveal that one of
lucy's brothers has got their hands on a
weapon that could have dire consequences
for the devil and even the world
in season one it was an untraceable gun
that a mena deal wanted malcolm to kill
lucifer with while in season 5b
it's a flaming sword which michael
claims to have though he's lying at that
point and which he intends to use to
beat lucifer in the latest celestial
battle
when god and the goddess finally exit
this world to live together in her
universe they do so at luther's club
pulling aside the curtains and walking
out into the light
all of which happens appropriately
enough right under the sign looks
the latin word for light luther decides
to pick up a new instrument this season
i think i'm going to learn the french
horn which is a fun hat tip to tom
ellis's own life as he actually learned
to play the french horn at the age of
eight or nine and played in orchestras
including the city of sheffield
youth orchestra throughout his teenage
years my friend shawn i'm just on my way
to chuck it out
while eve waits for her date to turn up
at the bar she drinks an apple teeny the
same tipple she ordered when she first
appeared in season four
though this time it comes complete with
a slice of apple all of which is a nice
nod to eve's backstory with what's often
thought to be the garden of eden's
forbidden fruit
just when michael thinks lucifer has
accepted him as a new god
are you ready to bend the knee brother
his devilish twin pulls a fast one you
are god awful
i mean what on earth are you wearing his
winter coming or something but lucifer
trash talking his brother's game of
thrones style gob
isn't the first time he's used the hit
show's famous phrase
back when chloe was worried about father
kinley's prophecy lucy asked her
what is it this time perhaps winter is
coming and i'm not sure if it's intended
but
at the family dinner when lucifer
noisily drags his chair to the head of
the table
i couldn't help but think of a certain
throne's character who also had a rather
difficult relationship with his family
when chloe reunites with her dad in
heaven they enjoy a picnic together and
in a lovely throwback to season two the
traditional deck of family egg
sandwiches are on the menu
egg sandwiches the decker family
tradition so good
grandpa used to bring me this sandwich
every thursday after acting class
sure by the way the actor who plays
chloe's father here is chris payne
gilbert real life husband of may's
actress
leslie ann brandt lucifer is met in
heaven by
lee a.k.a mr sit out [ __ ] who's been a
regular in the show's season premieres
over the years
and when lucy says he's been saved by
lilith's immortality ring
lee's reply i don't know what the [ __ ]
any of that means is a tribute to the
brilliant tv comedy the good play set in
the afterlife where cursed words are
censored in hilarious ways
somebody royally forked up why can't i
say fork maize breaks down when she
finds an old t-shirt dan had to pinch
after she knocked him out and left him
naked in chloe's bed back in season one
that n sync t-shirt which originally
belonged to chloe
reflects her love of 90s music something
lucifer has ripped her about over the
years
full of 90s jams i see the bengals msync
right sir fred and i go into full detail
on the masses of easter eggs and
references in the daniel espinosa naked
and afraid episode in my next video
countless hours of meticulous planning
dozens of favors called in
so tap here or click the link in the
description below for that video as soon
as it's ready
now what were your favorite moments in
the second part of season five
and did you spot any other easter eggs
or cool details
leave your thoughts in the comments
below tap left to watch my full loose of
a playlist including part two ending
explained and season six theories
or tap right for another video you're
sure to like and if you enjoyed this a
thumbs up and a share are hugely
appreciated
thanks for watching and see you next
time yippee kai movie lovers